the gaming world is eagerly awaiting  death stranding but what does that games  creator Hideo Kojima looking forward to  I'm Tony and this is your most  anticipated GameSpot news update in an  interview with games industry biz Kojima  revealed his most anticipated game of  2017 it's rockstars Red Dead Redemption  - the auteur has been a fan of rockstar  for a while he praised GTA 5 back in  2013 and called rockstars team the best  assuming it stays on schedule Red Dead  Redemption - will hit ps4 and Xbox one  in fall 2017 hopefully we'll hear some  real details soon as for Kojima's own  project death stranding is headed to ps4  and PC at some point in the future -  mysterious trailers have already dropped  so expect to see more next year to keep  up with everything from both Kojima and  Rockstar you're already in the right  place